hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the semi-finals of the
2019 feeder Grand Prix it's all sundar
group with the white pieces against the
Cara Nakamura the first game they played
in the semifinals ended in a draw so
it's a very important game for Nakamura
who now has to defend with the black
pieces to reach tiebreaks as these are
still classical time formats so before
we check out the game Alice I'll agree
she eliminated Sergey Kerrigan in the
quarterfinals we already mentioned that
as Carlton will be joining course and
England and Vishwanathan Anand in the
held indoors Abbey whisky distillery in
their chest Arts Tournament and he cor
Nakamura knocked out
Donald above course and second in his
match with Fabiano caruana also in the
quarterfinals so there we have it a nice
match between the two of them and we do
have a nice photo again compliments of
Nikki Riga that we have at the handshake
before the battle no no eye contact you
know this is a war no no friendships
allowed it's Russia versus the United
States like in the good old days so
let's let's just enjoy the game
Grisha has the white pieces like we said
and he opens with d4 and you already
know by now that we will have the Queens
gambit declined on the board Knight f6
we have c4 e6 Knight f3 and of course d5
so we have G 3x3 shocked and now Bishop
to e7
Bishop to g2 I'm gonna show pinky toes
the bishop with castles by nakamura
castles and here comes d captures on c4
and here I don't know if it's by design
I haven't caught the interview after the
game or haven't seen the live coverage
but if you have I don't know if agree
she was following that game but it's the
exact same game Dingley and played
against Economou Kimura in the cold war
blitz section that we've covered some
days ago but he brought an improvement
to this game we have d captures on c4
everything the same as in that game
Queen to c2 and now b5 again one of the
lines where it is possible to defend the
gambit pawn with a for a nice flank
attack to the b5 pawn B for now and here
at night f2 d2 opening up a discovered
attack towards the rock on a8 but also
preparing to capture the knight on c4 we
have c6 blocking the
Knight captures in c4 now grabbing that
pawn queen capture son d4 and now rook
to d1 pushing the Queen back Queen to c5
and now Bishop to e3 so like I said this
has all been played in the game dinkler
in versus Nakamura that I don't think we
covered it on this channel the game
ended in a draw but so far they are
covering it move by move queen h5 by
Nakamura and now comes Knight B to d2
with Knight to g4 now of course
pressuring the h2 pawn and now just
Knight to f3 defending the h2 pawn and
now Nakamura takes this opportunity to
eliminate grease shoots dark square
Bishop Knight captures and e3 we have
Knight captures on d3 and now a5 so up
up until this point it's exactly the
same game Nakamura already played
against ding leerin like we mentioned in
the boot section of the code a war 2019
and here Knight the c-4 was played by
ding and this game ended in a draw but
here with Knight to d4 it's not a new
move it was played before it is the
engines favorite so it would seem good
if you became very very well prepared
for this game and here there is there
are a couple moves that are known this
position Queen to c5 is a known move
just offering a queen trade and of more
notable games there is rook to e7 in
2012 we played this move against Jew in
June and that game ended in a draw but
here are Nakamura after this night
before plays Bishop to e6 it is a new
move and that it is now only as of move
16 that we have a completely new game
some of you mentioned in the comments
that I shouldn't call it a completely
new game because all of the moves up
until now have been played before but I
don't know I mean if it's now Bishop d6
was never played I I do think it's now a
completely new game I don't know if I
should may be using a new term I'm gonna
look into that but until I do I'm still
gonna go with the a completely new game
so rook 8 the c1 it's very interesting
if you capture us or not with the rook
but if you capture on c6 Knight captures
then black gets the e2 pawn for example
Knight captures Queen captures Bishop
captures here now attacks the rook you
have to do a nice rook lift rook d7 but
now you did rook a to see it at Aguilar
Queen F
the Queen moves and I are gonna go
Bishop to c5 and black has a very nice
attack Black has a lot of pressure black
has an extra pawn which he will keep
there's no way for white to regain it
and just overall a better position so
here after Bishop to e6
we have rook a to c1 and now comes Luke
the c8 it's now enough more has to
figure out how to develop this rook here
and this knight on b8 so there was a
that idea of rook to a7 in that position
which was played by Wei Yi and it is a
it is in fact the engines favorite so
way he was very well prepared for that
game but it is one of the ways to
develop the rook with Bishop to f3
attacking the Queen Queen to g6 and now
Bishop the e4 gireesham is not
interested in trading Queens he already
defended with the black pieces so now
when he has the white pieces he is very
much interested in grabbing a full point
he doesn't want to go into rapid rapid
playoffs if not necessary but shot back
to e4 now comes Queen to h5 and Bishop
to f3
I hear Grisha repeats and Nakamura just
repeats back he says okay I'm I mean I'm
I'm satisfied with a draw but shortly
for Queen to h5 and now Grisha doesn't
repeat he goes King to g2 so now of
course the game continues
rook 287 a Kimura decides to develop the
rook in the same way we did against the
Jew in June in 2012 and now comes h4 by
Grisham just increasing the pressure or
reducing the number of available squares
for for the black Queen we have g6 and
now comes f4 and now if you look at it
there really aren't all that many
squares this Queen can use none of these
squares are available to the to the
black Queen so we have Queen to h6 now
the Queen will be able to escape via the
dark squares and now comes Knight to b3
this Knight is now coming to c5 and it's
gonna be a very dangerous night if black
will want to eliminate it then black
will have to give up the bishop pair
with King clay trade by black and now
comes rushing back to d3
offering a trade of light square bishop
s-- with russia back to b7 nakamura
declines this and prepares c5 which will
with check we have Knight to c4 and now
c5 with check Bishop 3 for blocking and
now Bishop back to a6 still not
interested in trading off this light
square bishop but it does come with with
a price you do have to give up the a5
phone but there was no way to defend it
so it doesn't really matter with Knight
be capped for Sunday 5 and now you have
to again decide what to do if you
capture here you don't really gain
anything you still can't recapture on a4
as the Queen is not like that but the
Queen is guarding the a for porn so here
we have Queen back to f8 by Nakamura and
now butcher back to f3 rook to d8 now
offers the trade of rooks but now h5 we
should now continues the play on the
King side as well
Bishop to f6 assuming this very nice
diagonal and now comes rope capture son
d8 Queen captures on d8 and now just
look to d1 agree she claims the D file
for himself but rook to be 7 of course
you want to oppose this that's the idea
of ruke a 737 rook captures on d7 Knight
captures on b7 now finally the
Nakamura's Knight joins the game and now
h6 a very nice move by Grisha it will
you know remove a lot of squares from
from the black King side and the King
doesn't really have all that many
squares now if you know the Queen moves
from the front back rank the back rank
will become vulnerable any check to the
black King you know the King doesn't
have a lot of squares to go to but it's
a very interesting if Queen to f8 it's
important how do you defend the h6 pawn
well you defend it with the g4 and now
if Queen captures on h6 you don't push
g5 right away you don't want to allow
you already grabbed one point you don't
want to give up the g5 in the f4 pawn
black will very happily give up the
bishop for three points but first you're
just gonna go Queen to d2 attack the
knight that is on defender than b7 and
only after the knight moves now that the
Queen guards the g5 square as well will
push g5 and now it's just game over
black doesn't have a good reply to this
but you know it's it's you know a brave
idea h6 but you also have to be very
careful of moves like you know like this
we have night the b6 by nakamura of
the trade but now Knight to e5 we have
some characters on e5 it's a very strong
Knight not sure if I'm just gonna call
it a monster night just yet but you know
you are threatening to win the Queen so
the shock captures on e5 and now not an
automatic capture first Knight to c6
you're you're attacking the Queen and
you're gonna win the bishop this way
without messing up your pawn structure
which is the way you want to do things
in chess but here Nakamura just goes
Knight to c4 he says okay let's trade
Queens I'm done with playing the endgame
and I will try my chances there
so Knight capture some d8 and now nice
the III check which will of course pick
up the White Queen King to have to Black
has to grab the Queen we have Knight
captures on c2 now comes Knight captures
on f7 with Chuck King to g8 and only now
that's why to recapture the the piece
Knight captures on e5 and now c4 so okay
Nakamura is down upon but already he's
threatening c3 which will create a
passed pawn and you know things could
get very dangerous but goodie sugar
doesn't mind Bishop to g4 he says okay
you're free to push that I'm just gonna
capture then win the e6 pawn and it will
be an easy game I'm gonna be up two
points of course it's a it would be a
completely winning endgame so Nakamura
has to defend the e6 pawn he doesn't by
playing Knight to d4
but now King to e1 the King now also
joins the party with King to f8 now
comes King to d1 King the e7 and now
Grisha he's ready to win yet another
pawn has Nakamura brought his king t7
here you could also go to Knight
captures on g6 and it would be very
dangerous to recapture because then h7
is just winning but
grisha blue goes for a different line
III he just removes the defender of the
c6 square nice the b3 and now Knight to
c6 check just winning the b4 pawn it's a
different way to go about it
King to f6 now comes Knight captures and
b4 comes with an attack on the Bishop
Bishop goes to b7 and now Russia back to
e2
hoping to win yet another pawn with nice
- a 5 defending the c4 pawn but now came
to d2 the king is now coming to c3 then
you're gonna capture and the two
connected passports on the Queen side
will be more than enough to win this
game maybe
we have Knight to b3 check King to c3
and now comes Knight back to c5 and here
you don't want to trade at this point
for this pawn so first we should just
pushes it with a five-night the e4 check
gonna win the g3 pawn now kink after
some c4 Knight captures on g3 and now
Bishop to d3 nicely controlling the the
dark knight here with the Bishop g5 and
here we have just F captures and g5 and
it was in fact in this position animal
54 that he Cara Nakamura resigned the
game which is very unfortunate for him
because here
Grichuk now proceeds to the finals of
the feeder grand prix 2019 Nakamura is
eliminated and who knows I don't know as
the chests Arts Tournament in that
whiskey the story we discussed starts
tomorrow so I don't think Nakamura will
be interested in joining them or if it
was even an option for him but there are
already four players there so I don't
know if they're you know happily
receiving more of them but basically
there's really nothing to do here a 6 is
coming
whatever you do let's say King D 5 a 6
is coming and after we move the bishop
now you can just go Bishop captures on
e7 King captures here and after you
let's say attack this pawn here there's
no good way to defend it if you push a 5
then comes brush up to d5 you're gonna
trade bishops and of course then there's
a no good way of stopping the a6 pawn
and that's just game I mean there's no
counter play from black here so Nakamura
knows this after F captors and g5 he
resigned and an excellent victory for
Alexander grisha who knows who now
enters the finals of the Fida grand prix
2019 and he waits the winner of the
match Janna Pony vs. are also voice
check both both their classical games
ended in a draw so there they will have
to blow it out tomorrow you know in the
rapid and the bullets and the Armageddon
and whatnot so will be very interesting
will we have an all Russian brawl in the
finals or will rather shake have
something to say about that but you know
we'll just have to wait and see so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Alessio Tenaglia
and damien Stanley for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
happily awaiting the final so defeated
grand prix when I managed continuing the
Capablanca saga and of course checking
up on your suggestions I think you'll
have an excellent rest of your day and I
will see you soon